anyways what's up so I'm on here you
know I mean the Internet is a fire about
freaking Kanye West at the White House
and my question is what the [__] is
kanye west doing at the White House like
what there was no reason to get on him
that dudes crazy you know or he just he
not and he's not a normal person anymore
we near that rich and you're that famous
for that long
you don't run in regular society anymore
you got assistance and he's a part of
the Kardashian clan like they they
haven't been real they haven't been
regular for a long time they you know
they they got money they celebrity does
something to you so here's a guy who
like he admittedly been on he's had
issues and so yeah I don't care there's
a lot of people that got things to say
that want to go to the White House I
mean how many people do you think one
line up and go talk to Trump even if
it's just to be like man [__] you or or
or some racist organization that wants
to be like oh I love what you're doing a
lot of people want to go talk to the
president but does it mean that they
should be allowed like we need to stop
getting on Kanye West and we need to
start asking who the hell is advising
this dude I think I think they setting
him up for failure
I think Trump's inner circle is trying
to make him look bad do you think Obama
would have had some toilet paper on his
shoe you mean to tell me that nobody
nobody in his camp would have been like
Oh mr. president you you got a little uh
you got some on your shoe don't go out
there like that no I think his team was
like
[Music]
and they just let this [__] go I think
there's people in his camp sabotaging
him like how do you even get a meeting
with Trump does he just is he texting
does he got his number maybe he's got
his number he said Yomi can't come to
the White House could I come to your
work I don't understand like Trump's
having to bring a rapper to work day and
nobody on his team thought this was a
bad idea like not one person not one
person was like yo I don't think this is
I don't think we should do this come on
what I think that there should be a
higher regard for the president I think
the president shouldn't look like a fool
even if he's a fool the people around
him got to be like we have to hold this
freakin office to a higher standard
he shouldn't he should not have been
allowed to walk up those stairs
we toilet paper not one person ran form
not one person was like oh then let me
get this for you nah nobody everybody
was just like good and so the same thing
with this you just allow this dude to
come to the White House and make a
spectacle like that
the real question I maintain is what the
[__] was Kanye was doing at the White
House with all that press right there
man we have to hold there has to be a
higher standard for the freaking
president there has to be whether you
agree with them a lot or not I didn't
like when I do threw the shoe at Bush
remember when that happened to dude
threw a shoe at the president I don't
care if you'd like to dude or not you
don't throw a shoe at the goddamn
president that's just that's just
annoyed the hell out of me even then I
don't even like that dude I didn't like
when Obama was speaking to Congress and
somebody yelled out you're a liar
I was like what that kind of [__] should
not be allowed and in the same way this
do should not be in
office spoutin like who cares what Kanye
West thinks I don't know why people are
so worried about what this rapper thinks
he obviously it's not like are you
surprised it's not like he was a normal
dude and then all of a sudden he went
off his rocker you like whoa what
happened to that guy you like he feet
maybe he's running a game on the whole
country that'd be funny I mean that'll
be funny of later he comes out with some
rap album he's trash and Trump and like
you know you can I can't believe you let
me come to the White House or whatever
he would do I just I'm just tired of
hearing like the dude don't speak for
anybody but himself or just rich little
elite who else is he speaking for you
know and why cuz like what kind of
egomaniac needs that dude like there's
no one in Trump's camp that was like
well you know people are already off a
Kanye from the thing he said about
slavery so they already off him so if we
bring him in who is it who is it helping
other than Trump's ego does he need
support from celebrities that much that
Kanye West is the one that makes him
feel special I just don't get it I don't
get it who else was going colder to
White House you know who else is going
like I mean I mean it's like what other
crazy rappers would he have at the White
House just to be like see I mean he's
got his base he got his base you know he
must be how Lavar ball come to the White
House I mean that would be equivalent to
Kanye West that's it levar ball comes to
the White House he's just talking to him
guy you need this big baller brand in
the White House
big baller brand I mean what else that
is equivalent to the nonsense of having
Kanye West and then and then [__]
Twitter going crazy every
buddy's going crazy I saw a pastor say
[__] today a pastor was like
this [__] coronary worth I just
say who cares bro
we really should be talking about why he
was even there I must say again I think
that they are sabotaging the dude I
think there's people in Trump's inner
circle or like who who don't want to
come out and be like they don't they
don't support him so they're just trying
to like make him look bad oh man I'm
telling you guys
y'all got to stop talking about talking
about him I'm up here talking about him
we got to stop talking about him we got
to start talking about who we gonna put
in office who's gonna run against him
who's gonna run against him do you know
when he names
does anybody know any names okay is it
gonna be Cory Booker Warren who's it
gonna be
cuz we need to start talking about that
[__] every day just dude is so
famous just people making drawings
I mean SNL needs to send this dude a
gift basket thank you cuz this is the
highest ratings we've ever had even won
Emmys
thanks to this do being in office every
late-night show every late-night show
nobody's even listening to or watching
anymore or the ones that they're ratings
have gone through the roof when they
start talking about this dude why would
you think he's not gonna win again
man I don't know what the hell's going
on I don't know I just don't know but
other countries the other countries they
can look at us and say all they want but
they still gotta respect us because no
matter what happens in four years eight
years six more years it'll be somebody
new and they know this system will keep
going it'll just keep going and then
we'll have somebody new and then the
ideological changes will happen again so
everybody's got to be cautious
everywhere else can't be like who do we
like him do we like America this this
for years because in another four years
the holy Konami [__] might change cuz
somebody new comes in there I just think
it's ridiculous that Kanye West was at
the White House and I find it even more
ridiculous that everybody's up in arms
about it and the things he was saying
stop being surprised when somebody out
of touch says something out of touch
right don't even make any sense I mean I
don't like what you know here's another
thing to his point of view his point of
view is like I don't it's not
necessarily wrong it's misguided you
know he if he's trying to sound like
he's being provocative or you know he's
trying to be nuanced but it just comes
off like what just do go rap or
something I think you make a bigger
impact sometimes people even with this
kind of thing doing a podcast I'm a
comic I'm supposed to be on stage making
jokes but this is the new media new art
form new new platform for people to talk
I don't know if I'm good
am I good at this I don't know I mean is
this what I'm supposed to be doing I'm
not gonna come off crazy like Kanye West
when I start talking about stuff maybe
maybe I will be crazy but damn you know
I mean it's like what are we talking
about right now you know I mean I keep
thinking who's who would be somebody
else I think it's having Kanye West go
to the White House would be like if
David Duke went to the White House or
you know somebody that has a clear
distinct point of view that kind of
point of view shouldn't be around the
President of the [__] United
States that's my point no matter what
your extreme view is if your extreme if
your extreme liberal if some if some
huge social socialist wants to come in
and be like there should be health care
for everyone there should be you know
well we should be a bigger welfare state
if somebody like
shouldn't go talk to the president
either somebody extremely racist
shouldn't go talk to the president and
something like Kanye West should not be
sitting in front of the president who
are his people man
he needs a no man you know he needs
somebody so many people need that so
many people need somebody going hey I
don't think you should do that Michael
Jackson needed to know man you know when
he was like I want to get some llamas
somebody should have been like nah nah I
don't think he should get llamas no
that's nah nah Michael I don't yeah you
should wear two gloves maybe two gloves
you know he just needed somebody like
that to help him you know all of these
kind of people they need somebody to
help hey everybody so that I'm looking
down here if anybody got a question
you know whoever's listening right now
you watching me you know I'm looking at
my little screen right here so if you
want to give me a little question or
something on let's interact this is
still my pre podcast pre riffing with
Griffin you know I haven't even this is
just all teasers there's me coming on
I'm still testing out the equipment and
figuring everything out I'm still in San
Diego at the film festival my movie I
hear electric love it's on iTunes right
now you can get it on iTunes electric
love it's actually a sweet little movies
dope it's like a little piece of candy
you can open up and go it's good this is
a good piece of candy but I was at this
party and somebody was talking about it
and I was like damn talking about Kanye
West and I was like wow I think Trump
might be evil genius so we're not even
still talking about him I mean we got
the midterm elections coming up and
people are harping on Kanye West maybe
somebody on his team is actually
brilliant who knows I can't figure it
out I cannot figure it out I don't know
listen I don't have a problem with a
Kanye West having an opinion y'all I
have no problem with it I think even if
it's misguided even if it's like
whatever you know
he got a lot of money he's sitting on a
lot of money he travels he makes his
music he's an artist he's a
temperamental artist his sound keeps
changing his ideas keep changing it's
like that's what happens to people like
that but a person like that shouldn't be
at the White House that's my point
right am I wrong who thinks I'm wrong I
don't know
I just I just I just have no clue oh all
right I got that out yeah man I feel
like I mean do you think Trump and Kanye
West actually hang out what does it say
about Donald Trump that he needs someone
like that to speak in the way that he's
speaking for him I mean damn why what
does Donald Trump really think a Kanye
West I mean he was sitting at the desk
looking at him like damn did I make a
mistake and then like the dude just got
up walked around the desk and like you
know show the president something on his
phone like where's where's where the
Secret Service action like is that was
the most bizarre thing I've ever seen
but this is the times we live in I mean
we have to start wrapping our brains
around the president is on Twitter like
that's crazy
and what is the next iteration of this
gonna look like what is the next leader
of the free world gonna be doing you
know huh
she's crazy
I mean being relevant is important you
know what I mean like I'm saying this
are you gonna buy a kanye album like
this will do what he say gonna make you
be like odd I think this dude's music is
wack are you taking a stand like that I
mean just just I'm saying they do that
just fought Conor McGregor whatever that
other dudes name is you know he's a
great fighter skill talented undefeated
but there's rumors that he has some ties
to like some bad Russian people so you
know just one thing affect the other
thing so there's it does Kanye's views
and opinions are you gonna be like I'm
never gonna listen to his music again
you know I mean it I agree
I'm not gonna just two comments it is
crazy
Donald Trump has been on The Comedy
Central Roast he's the President of the
United States I think you I think Obama
should just come out and be like just do
all that stuff I think I think it'll be
dope if Obama like had a reality show on
TV you know like the it would be great
if they just did like The Apprentice or
like The Apprentice but not the
apprentice but like like a political
apprentice and Obama was the leader you
know he was the he was the the main host
you know and it was like you have to go
out and do politics so it's not about
business it's just about politics and
then he like fires congressmen and
people like that well she just put
himself in the public eye [__] it
and we shouldn't roast Obama I brought
my mom a roast you know he should be out
there at basketball games all the time
just kid out there I just don't
understand just
we what this is a crazy world man da the
president made a president of another
country curse on Twitter he wasn't the
president yet but he almost was I
remember New Mexico Mexican president
was like we're not building that [__]
wall like wow that's a little bit
gangster is it a little bit gangster to
make somebody come out they scan like
that like what is it to be presidential
anymore
have you guys ever asked yourself that
what is it to be presidential because
cuz I don't know you know I mean I don't
I just don't know what it means anymore
I'm trying to figure it out but I can't
I mean I wish I knew you know to be
presidential somebody tell me does
anybody know what it means to be
presidential huh whatever I'm trying to
think who would be the craziest person
to run for president that's equivalent
to Donald Trump right now I mean I don't
know
is there anyone like that you know is
there anyone that's like some fringe
candidate it's just like we're talking
about the rock he's talking about the
room like few mentions of the I mean at
this point Donald Trump has made it
we're know how anybody can be president
like anybody you know like there's
nothing regal about the office anymore
that's the thing I don't like y'all
politics aside you know whatever you
want to think I don't think that any
president who's in office if he if he
polarizes the country if you you can't
bring people together you're not a good
leader you're not a good leader not good
and it goes and we haven't had one in a
long time do we ever have one that
really galvanizes people to be like okay
let's work together let's see
like one nation none of them I'm trying
to get some people that I sent out some
text messages today to a lot of my
friends like y'all I need you on the
podcast I need you to come on you know
so I got some interviews lined up a lot
of people said they would do it some
people didn't get back to me it's all
good
I know it's annoying I think asking
people to be on your podcast is like
asking people to move can you help me
move these things I don't like let's go
over the list I don't want to read your
script okay I don't want to read your
script all right I'm not I'm not a
studio so if I don't know you well you
want me to take the time to read your
script like [__] please mad I've done
it I have a few really close friends or
people that I I respect their work but
even still it's like you want me to read
your script get out of here - I'm not
gonna take you to the airport okay
it's 2018 get a lift [__] you
know what I mean what you know what I
can see Donald Trump coming on my
podcast I'm just looking at this that's
how stupid we are right now that he'd be
like oh that podcast only got like a
hundred subscribers I'm going on that
they'll be sweet that would be actually
dope if Donald Trump came on my podcast
that would be dope you can say what you
want but anyways I don't want to read
your script I don't want to take you to
the airport
I don't want to help you move I don't
why would I want to help you move who
are you why what oh I don't want to I
don't want to move I don't want to move
my [__] what a [__] would I want to move
your [__] it's nonsense man it's
nonsense
and I don't want to be on your podcast
but I do it you know some of them are
great you know you know a lot of love
but that's just some one of those things
I get people hitting me up all the time
hey can you be on my podcast
I don't know you but what are you
talking about
but this is the new medium new platform
not here I am being a hypocrite cuz I'm
asking people like yo come on my podcast
I mean you write Obama did go on Marc
Maron
I mean if Obama can go on Marc Maron
Donald Trump can come on Griffin with
Griffin we should just put that out
there that's the thing if we gotta start
tweeting out Trump come on riffing with
Griffin and let's talk buddy let's air
that this air your grievances let's just
get everything out you know let me give
you some advice that would be hilarious
all right let me go to the what people
are saying here I'm dying up here was a
great show we made 20 great episodes but
we are cancelled so that's that I'm
dying up here is not coming back
but I enjoyed it what do you guys think
of that thing right there there's a dick
no it's over here there it is
my riffing with Griffin am i doing it
right I think I am somebody made that
for me it's pretty dope he said I can
use it like that a lot um anyways let me
just get off or I just keep yapping and
yapping about nothing I guess that's
what this is for right trust adjust yep
yep about another thing you know what I
really like I got the equipment all set
up great I love how my voice sounds I'm
all deep what's up girl how you doing
how you doing Twitter how you doing we
talked about Kanye West here on rhythm
when Griffin we talked about Kanye West
on
riffin with Griffin
I should get Kanye on here to put that
out there this tweet all that out Kanye
to come on riffing with Griffin and
Donald Trump to come on riffing with
Griffin I'll be great even one of the
Trump kids that'd be awesome
do you think Donald Trump is gonna get
impeached or is he gonna go to jail or
is he gonna get reelected that's the
pole how do you think he's going to jail
[Music]
he's gonna get arrested impeached or is
he gonna just go scot-free
nothing's gonna come out of the
investigation and then it's never gonna
touch him I don't know what if if they
impeach him then we have to do with
pence like pence pre Trump someone like
Mike Pence would never ever be this
close to being president like never but
now no holds bar I think he's gonna go
scot-free
I remember when Trump got in office and
I my buddy Ben he every day oh this he's
gonna get impeached he's going to jail
yeah all the stuffs gonna come out
tomorrow and that's gonna be it
I'm just waiting [__] went off from
weeks and weeks and months and months
and I'm like dude every day on his
Facebook every single day some story
from CNN oh this is that this is the one
they got him they got him they got him
this time like call me when they really
got him please all the credibility
there's no credibility I'm so tired of
all of the news just just stop
you know what I think it'd be dope I
think cuz they're not to me they're all
the same
you know like MSNBC Fox News I don't see
a difference you know I see smug opinion
people they they're all they're all
podcasts that's all Sean Hannity is just
a podcast it's just a do you know but
it's set up like news it just looks like
news but it's not news
they're just opinion people I want to
see Freaky Friday Sean Hannity and
Rachel Maddow baby they meet in the
bathroom and all of a sudden goo it's
freaky for we wouldn't even be able to
tell the difference I mean they got the
same haircut how would we even know I
think they did do Freaky Friday when
Rachel Maddow was like member where she
had two taxes it was like you know
tuning and this is gonna be the
blockbuster this is gonna be the most
important news story ever and then she
showed that the year she had the
[__] paid his taxes that was the
big reveal oh my god people are so
[__] stupid
that was like Capone's vault
remember when Capone like you open
Capone's vault and there was nothing in
it that's what that Rachel Maddow story
was about the taxes there was nothing in
the vault like they're all the same
would that be dope it's like Rachel
Maddow I Sean Hannity they they Freaky
Friday and they're like you know they
started talking opposite but then they
would be like actually I why do I still
sound the same and be crazy you know
people like to get on Fox you know the
problem is it's the name is called Fox
News right so that's how we even say it
we don't even say news when we talking
about CNN we just say C and n we say
MSNBC you know we say BBC Fox is the
only one that we say the word News Fox
News we don't go FN so like so then
therefore in our heads we think that
that's supposed to be new
the actual news programs on Fox I gotta
tell you they not have bad they not it's
very it's not that much in the day where
they're actually doing news someone else
people are always getting on Trump's
case it's everything else is these
opinion people and it looks like news I
think that the people that are giving
opinions they should be sitting in
[__] couches and [__] like this if
Sean Hannity was sitting in a chair like
this you would be like oh this
[__] just talking well that's
just his own opinion you don't got to
worry about it but when he has a desk in
front of them in some white pieces of
paper and a [__] green screen board
that he can go to fax then you go well
this looks just like what the news is
supposed to look like and we keep saying
Fox News it's all [__] y'all is all
bull [__]
oh well anyways I got a commercial
audition in the morning I mean yeah back
to commercials y'all I'm dialing papers
canceled so I got to go do a trying to
get a I'm trying to I'm trying to hustle
I'm doing my hustle I'm gonna be in
Winnipeg I'm gonna be in Winnipeg next
week if anybody's interested on my any
Canadian fans now I see a question do
you care that canary is a Republican or
that he supports Trump I think first of
all I think anybody that starts making a
lot of money becomes more conservative
fiscally conservative you know when you
may get a bunch of money and then you
see other amount of taxes that you have
to pay and you know you just naturally
become fit I think most people are
fiscally conservative they want to be
they want to like let's take care of our
money that's make sure that the
financial system is set up in a way that
our money can grow everybody's like that
but then we want to be socially liberal
we want to like make sure people are
taken care of you know so I don't know
what side of the fence you know Kanye
West er says is on but it's not as
simple as Republican liberal or who you
know it's more rich in Poor's more rich
middle-class poor it's even more than
that super rich rich you know when
people say rich people's these ain't
$250,000 you don't think that's a lot of
money do you really think that's a lot
of money if you don't have a lot of
money then yes I could see how you would
think that $250,000 at a lot of money so
you have five people in your house you
got a lawyer and a doctor knee and
combined they make two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars so you mean to tell me
you think that's wealthy that's that's
considered wealthy so like me you know I
ain't making a lot of money one year I
probably made two and fifty thousand
dollars so you trying to tell me that
it's me
jay-z Warren Buffett and Bill Gates
we're all wealthy we're all in the same
category
really [__] if you made 250,000 you're
getting 40% tax that 250 now becomes a
hundred and fifty so now you got a 150
okay uh are you are you renting are you
you know are you playing a mortgage is
your mortgage three or four thousand
dollars a month are you leasing cars did
you buy a car are your kids in public
school are they in private school are
you spending you know thirty forty
thousand dollars on that for them you're
paying insurance like what are you doing
you think that that 150 you have left is
is gonna go a long way yeah if you're
somebody that only makes $30,000 you
think [__] what you complaining about if
I had that you would live differently if
you only making $30,000 in your rent is
$900 a month in you and I gave you 250
would you move yes [__] you
would move you would now be like I'm not
gonna afford $4,000 now that's 60 what
is that you know you talk about forty
eight thousand sixty thousand dollars a
month just to you know you got to eat
you got to live I mean people don't
really understand the value what money
how much things cost but what's the real
value of money
people don't know anyways I feel like
I'm going I'm becoming a crazy person
does what happens when you have a
podcast you just sitting out here
talking to yourself but daddy's got to
go I'm excited to do more again I'm
gonna have guests you know I'm gonna
have you know people on it's gonna be
great with it with Griffin look at the
little guy right yeah with it with
Griffin anyways guys thanks for being a
part of it and I will catch you on the
flipside